who would be someone for yourself who
might be the I not necessary
unattainable because I'm sure at this
point anyone is fairly attainable but
someone you haven't had on and you might
not have a relationship with that you'd
love to get on the show I have to come
up with an answer for that question
Michael Jackson I mean I don't have a
good answer to that I'm tom that's a
good no no I don't want to hold on you
wouldn't wanna mind just oiling my stage
I don't know you would want to have a
candid conversation with no I don't he
has a candid conversation with the world
every day that's enough is this a
convenience dream or you think you think
you can this Donald Trump being a
Canadian it's amazing to watch but you
think it can ever be beat to death there
was a community dream to have a
president like this because there's so
much material I don't know if it's a
dream for a comedian it's definitely
bountiful so there's a lot of material I
mean I would easily exchange the amount
of material it allows the creative mind
in for a real president I would much
rather have somebody that deserves to be
in that office be there so but yeah
obviously there's a lot to play with and
it's a lot I mean it's a lot of fun to
make fun of him because he's such a
[ __ ] so you had said congratulations to
Nick because he did something all
Americans want to do Mary Mary Canadian
now Ryan Reynolds is taken Ryan Gosling
has taken Justin Trudeau's taken if
there was a Canadian that you could
potentially marry and blaze take him to
play thank you speak so Drake still
available but if there was a Canadian
out there you could marry to get a
Canadian passport would you marry did
you go for probably my ski guide i go to
whistler and ski every I mean that would
be the safest because he's already
married and that would be perfect I
would just have them divorced his wife
and we'd have an understanding i come
over they could get married again we get
divorced there'd be a nice little
thruple situation where's your happy
place outside of work like are you an
avid reader you're obviously you
obviously ski but where's your place
where you take back relaxing can kind of
really so now I've kicked back and
relaxed when I'm on vacation so I take a
lot of vacations a lot of my work and
vacation kind of go like this
so it kind of the dovetails nicely I've
kind of figured out a way to work and
vacation vacation in between my lunch
breaks is that really what it is well I
mean you surround yourself with people
that you have fun with now so that you'd
want to hang out with them whether
you're working or not I try to do that I
try to be around people that like I want
to be around so that I don't want to bow
out and like go back to my room and then
you want to floor together so it's like
a little you know kind of like a little
band of idiots is there is there a
moment from this past season a taping a
moment that is special that kind of
stands out to you yeah probably the day
after the election when I had Senator
Barbara Boxer on and my best friend Mary
McCormack was on and we cried on air
which I never thought I would ever ever
ever do and it was like so unexpected
and it was real but it was like gritty
and Barbara Boxer was just so incredible
about day to me because I didn't think I
could do the show and I was so upset and
she was just such a kind of like guiding
force about like getting through
something and it's okay it was okay that
we cried it wasn't the end of the world
you didn't make a fool out of yourself
you know like it was real and and that
was like something I never thought I
would ever be able to do I mean I don't
like to cry at all so crying on camera
was not like it was embarrassing why do
you think it affected you so much
because it's the human rights issue
where we have like a lunatic in the
White House who is like acting like I'm
like a toddler and so a lot of people
are in danger everyone is in danger what
do you think that you know sometimes
things like this happen is there happens
to be a set of false sense of security
so to speak maybe in the US where
there's a lot of issues that are maybe
under the search now now coming to the
service that everyone's alone this still
exists this still is out there and it
kind of gives people the ability to see
what's out there and kind of combat it
and yeah I think it's a great it's been
limited and a lot of things in this
country and a lot of the stuff that's
got like an underbelly of this country a
lot of what people have been ignored and
a lot of issues have been ignored so I
think something really beautiful can
come out of this and I think just the
unification of people already and the
way people have come together in the
marches and the like you know and not
letting up its been so impactful and
powerful that there is going to be a
silver lining
not happen right away but it's happening
and the result of it may not be seen for
a while but it's definitely a different
type of place now there's a unification
that wasn't here six months ago and it
would have helped if we had been
together like that six months ago but
whatever it didn't happen so what's
happening now and I feel it